the family of a man who died you know
Georgia jail is filing a lawsuit and
calling on the Justice Department to
investigate what they say is a troubling
pattern of misconduct 22 year old Shah
lead Tilson died of dehydration at the
Rockdale County Jail in March of 2018
another inmate died in the same Atlanta
area jail less than three months later
an attorney for both families claims
deputies at the jail were negligent and
says the County Sheriff does not have
control over the deputies some of whom
have been linked to alleged crimes
themselves the Mount Carmel DeMarco
Morgan spoke to the families suing
Rockdale County in interviews you will
see first on CBS this morning
DeMarco good morning it's a disturbing
story on so many levels
mashaallah Tilson's family says he had a
known history of mental illness Tilson's
lawyer says deputies used force on him
at least six times while in jail he also
points out we all have loved ones
struggling with mental health issues and
warns this could happen to any of them I
know my son's not resting in peace
Phoenicia Tilson and Vladimir Joseph say
jail workers let their 22 year old son
shali Tilson die in his cell I can't
even think of the words to describe what
I'm feeling
they set there and watched him die a
slow horrible cruel death the way his
person might do it trying to get in it's
a form of Tennessee I don't know drunk
award
Tilson was arrested last March for
disorderly conduct after allegedly
beating on the door to an apartment
where he used to live he was then taken
to Rock Dale County Jail outside Atlanta
body camera footage shows Tilson
speaking erratically as police restrain
him a lawsuit filed by Tilson's family
says he was schizophrenic the suit also
says he was in the midst of a medical
crises at the time of the arrest and
required immediate medical attention but
was instead placed in solitary
confinement it also alleges deputies
neglected their duties falsified their
watch logs and on the day Tilson died he
pressed the emergency call button in his
cell but it did not work he
literally crying out for help
and no one listened tilson family lawyer
Molly Davis the failure of human beings
not treating him like a human being they
had video surveillance inside of his
cell 24 hours a day they were required
to go in every 15 minutes and check on
him because they placed him into suicide
watch did that happen
it did not according to the lawsuit
Tilson died from dehydration less than
two weeks after his arrest he had to go
at least 2 to 3 days with an inadequate
amount of water 2 to 3 days there was
another woman who died Jaime Henry Jaime
Henry's family says she was found a dead
in her cell at Rockdale County Jail less
than three months after Tilson died
Henry was arrested for violating
probation Davis says the jail failed to
treat the 40 year old mother of one for
symptoms of withdrawal and says she died
from complications related to cocaine
and morphine Robert Thompson and Jamie
Henry were together for 10 years
she blatantly asked him for help I mean
I know her better than anybody do and if
she's sick I know she's not gonna keep
her mouth closed
the Larry Donaldson is Henry's father so
you believe that somebody needs to pay
for what happened payback what that's
not gonna solve anything
but somebody should be helpers somebody
should be held responsible correct Davis
says the Rockdale County Sheriff's
Office has a long-standing and pervasive
lack of control over its employees and
local news reports linked certain
individual deputies to various alleged
crimes including illegal drug
distribution stalking sexual battery and
illegal firearms it's clearly something
going on in that jail Davis is now
calling on the Department of Justice to
investigate the deaths if there is
injustice for shali if there isn't
justice for Jamie Henry how can we know
that people will be safe
it's a good question CBS news reached
out to the Rockdale County Sheriff's
Office for combat and they referred us
to a statement from last month and that
statement the sheriff's office said they
will review and act on any findings once
all the investigative reports are done
they also said their hearts go out to
the families of those affected but I got
to tell you I'm reminded of what was
said by a Camden police officer that I
interviewed I think was about a year or
two ago but he said whenever you're
dealing with someone whenever you arrest
someone you have to always look at them
as human beings first before you can see
them as a criminal that could be
somebody's father that could be
somebody's brother you name it but to
sit in somebody's Jail for three days
without water is unacceptable on every
level and not one but two deaths I mean
someone clearly dropped the ball here
there are a lot of questions for the
Rockland County Jail that need answering
the mark oh thank you for that